YURI GRINSHTEYN: In
Stackdriver, metrics
are used to understand the
change of numeric values
over time.
And logs, they're used
to capture specific point
in time events.
But what if you need
to understand how
those events change over time?
You can use Stackdriver to
create metrics from logs,
and I'll show you how.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Google Cloud logs contain
a wealth of information,
but it's hard to analyze trends
without additional steps,
such as exporting
them to BigQuery
and using a visualization tool.
Stackdriver log-base metrics
allow you to count records
based on a filter.
You can also track
numeric values
to easily convert logs
to metrics you can
use for analysis and alerting.
Let's start with
a simple example.
We have an application that
writes errors out to logs.
Now we'd like to create
a chart that shows us
how many errors we get
and an alert that lets
us know if we get too many.
We can create a counter metric
from those error logs simply
by clicking the
Create metric button
and selecting counter
as the metric type.
The metric will count the
number of entries that
match our filter every minute.
The metric is then available
in Stackdriver Monitoring
under the logging
slash user domain.
We can create charts
using in dashboards
and configure alerting
policies using it.
That was easy enough.
We now have a way to use
log-base metrics to count
how many errors we see.
Let's take a look at a
more complicated scenario.
In the case of a
successful transaction,
our application writes out
a log message that tells us
how long the transaction took.
We want to track that value
and chart application latency.
Here's the log message
with the latency recorded.
To do that, we'll create
a distribution metric.
To do that, click on Create
metric, select Distribution
as the metric type, and
specify a regular expression
to extract the
numeric value we're
after from a field
in the log payload.
The counter metric we
created earlier just
counted the number of entries
that matched our filter.
This distribution
metric will instead
track the numeric
value we care about.
Just like before,
our new metric is
available in
Stackdriver monitoring,
and we can create a chart
tracking its values over time.
We can also use our
log-base metrics
for alerting, just
like any other metric
available in
Stackdriver monitoring,
by using it as a condition
and then alerting policy.
One more great thing you should
know about log-base metrics
is that they make it
really easy to see
the log entries that were used
to build the metric values.
From a chart, you can
simply click on View Logs
to see the logs for the metric.
While logs and metrics are often
used for different purposes,
you may have a need
to create metrics
that help you analyze log data.
Stackdriver log-base metrics,
both counter and distribution,
allow you to do just that.
Thank you for joining me today,
and come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor,
stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]